bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fari j
oggi siamo su ma era un videogame indie
horror che ci tenevo veramente
tantissimo a fare perché ha
un'ambientazione che ho visto che mi
inquieta un casino io sono masochista
vado a fare sti giochi e direi di
iniziare subito allora andiamo su play
by cos'è appena virtuosi con risorse
sono promosse altri corrono 6 non
capisci un cazzo però che non mi
interessa cosa dice quindi andiamo
avanti
raga ok go sesto posto
raga siamo entrati in una sala ragazzi
c'è una sedia adesso mi interroga le b
ai mi sa di sì è ok
raga vedo un corridoio c'è qualcosa che
non va
come fai sacino stanza del genere poi
esserci un corridoio fatemi capire se ma
con la cazzo di sedia che co raga c'era
una sedia di prima da dove sono uscito
lo aspettate un attimo ma non sto
capendo cosa è successo c'era una sedia
qui rai aiuto
beh bene c'è un c'è sono in un posto
raga non ho capito bene che cazzo sta
succedendo
[Applauso]
ok
raga praticamente mi stanno dicendo che
è quella sedia state dette
praticamente mi hanno detto che quella
sedia lì da dove sono partito quella
bianca dell fbi era una sedia una
sottospecie di sedia teletrasporto e
quindi praticamente mi hanno
teletrasportati st zona però non
riescono a farmi tornare indietro
perfetto ragazzone in una zona ignota in
una casa fantastica che corridoi della
madonna è bene è fantastico sto posto
già lo amo cazzo va bene direi di andare
avanti rai allora non capisco bene che
qualcosa quella roba laggiù c'è qualcosa
la gioco
raga iniziamo allora c'è qualcosa laggiù
non so bene che cos'è porca [ __ ]
cos'è sta roba chi sei tu senti e ti sei
perso io sono arrivato qui non farà che
che cazzo è successo
ebbene allora 20 mi fai paura mi fai
paura io me ne vado me ne vado e grazie
mille dell'ospitalità porca [ __ ] vai
via vai via vai piani ognuno sa cosa c'è
scritto qui c'è qualcosa di strano a
proposito di questo sogno
raga sono in una specie di sogno tipo
inception è senti zio io chiudo la porta
qui perché mite
[Musica]
raga che cazzo succede raga
cos'è aiuto mi sembra ti poteri michiara
gama impressionante succede è che cazzo
air ottico hai rotto il cazzo hai rotto
chiavari via board caputa va a giocare
con le carte dei pokémon che è che cos'è
ragazzo sesto posto ma solo io li trovo
sia porca [ __ ] [ __ ]
cos'è che cazzo ma [ __ ] porca
[ __ ] è tuo amico quello fammi capire
mio addio santissimo che cazzo di colpo
raga questo sto gioco impressionante
porca [ __ ]
e va bene qua non si apre la pa pt porca
[ __ ] che c'è il bambino che mi segue
apriti attestate ti apro a presenti mi
fa piacere già dato che non serve un
cazzo apri almeno stavolta aiuta
va beh sì sì va bene io non ti pago vado
via grazie mille ti rendi utile vabbè io
tornare indietro ragazze sto qui che mi
ha fatto una paura
porca put ceca te che cazzo la carne
pure in mezzo italiani dobbiamo raga non
ho capito allora devo riuscire a tornare
indietro
praticamente tipo inception mi buttano
in un sogno particolare che non è così
bello come sogno e devono farmi tornare
indietro ma non sapevano come cos'è sta
roba
sì non capisco il francese ma non
importa la mia ignoranza in materia
francese e leggenda cazzo capisco di più
il portoghese e quello di difesa dell o
comunque vabbè andiamo a vantato devo
continuare pesa delo che cazzo è raga ci
sono delle sedie questa più o meno la
mia classe quando la lasciamo prima di
uscire dall'aula sono all'amica avesse
tu così vero no raga aiuta cos'è se
qualcuno che arriva carretta class era
quella roba c'era c'era qualcuno
nell'alto corridoio l'ho visto l'ho
visto merda lo vince un'altra ma che
cazzo pinoni porta il suo posto di merda
pieno di forte inutile ragazzotto io non
ci torno indietro senti stronzo vai
avanti tu
raga io o vai avanti tu beauty segue a
ruota dai nuovi il culo cazzo fa
qualcosa
raga è traumatizzante c'è qualcosa che
ho visto laggiù e l'avevo vista guardate
la vedo c'è una roba nera laga io devo
andare di qua però andare di coca e ciò
fatta ce l'ho fatta c'era qualcosa di
nero molto brutto ma non lo so c'è
sempre bambino che mi segue attento
dietro che c'è qualcuno
raga è impressionante sto gioco è fatto
con lo unity engine tipo quello di slang
praticamente ma perché si spegne la luna
ma io dovrei aiuto aiuto che cazzo cos'è
quella roba cosa giusta
checa porca [ __ ] due volte per le
successo
raga la cosa impressionante cos'è store
ma cosa cazzo appena giocato vabbè io
direi di riprovarci la caccia da
possiamo fare allora siamo di nuovo
nella stanza ok questa chiuse prima era
per a ok adesso si apre adesso voglio
vedere se le scorse la fisso magari non
scompare infatti non sta scomparendo ma
se faccio così no c'è ancora allora che
cazzo cioè prima mi prendevi per il culo
c'è che cosa cazzo dovrei fare qui prima
era scomparsa perfetto ci siamo
doveva scomparire in un modo o
nell'altro allora siamo andati la prima
io non ci vado più di là che cos'è
questo buongiorno sentite one direction
c'è mica qualcuno che sa di voi come
cazzo si esce da qui cos'è sta roba
sì bella foto cazzo fantastico come si
fa dove sono
vabbè io uscirei di qua tanto raga le
porte non capisco come si aprono e odio
cos'è l'one zio ma c'è un coltello
c'è un coltello c'è un coltello e del
sangue benissimo cazzo iniziamo da dio
questo secondo questo secondo round
ebbene ragazze allora sto gioco
veramente fantastico un'atmosfera degna
di hello kitty ragazzo è caduto un
quadro e io non ho fatto un cazzo
io non ho fatto un cazzo senti è caduto
io non ho toccato niente io fa guardavo
e caduto da solo non rimproverate ma
cos'è successo anzi di nuovo quello che
mi dice che non posso tornare indietro
del capito va bene qualcuno ma per
chiedevi comparirvi così stavo stavo
così bene prima perché devi venirmi
dietro stavo così bene cazzo stavo bene
invece devi arrivare tu a rompere i
[ __ ]
sei stato tu a far cadere il quadro di
la verità bastardo vabbè andiamo avanti
tanto seguimi ormai siamo affiatati noi
due
cos'è praga praga praga praga ragazzi
spengono le luci che cazzo sto bambino
di merda devono riuscire ad andare da
dove cazzo da dove sono arrivato io che
dico allora andiamo dall'altra parte
perché leasys vengono dell'oggi e non è
un bene andiamo di quadra quasi sono
porte chiuse non si può andare di qua
perfetto c'è una sedia e lo so
sei stato tu a correre dimmi la verità o
no perché finora sei stato buono e
tranquillo se cominci a correre tifi con
calcio che ti faccio volare su quella
sedia porca [ __ ] vedi ke kazzo di
volo ti fai
e va bene devo andare da voi ragazzi
siamo di nuovo lo eravamo prima allora
ho capito dobbiamo tornare allora
calmiamoci un attimo cosa non siamo
riusciti a fare prima
c'è un quadro laggiù che prima non l'ho
visto magari anche questo cade raga
aiuto cos'è aiuto e di volo e l'affare
si chiude la val badia via via via via
via via via ok via via via via via è
andato quindi posso tornare
devo raggiungere il quadro cazzo se no
non vado avanti mi sa che nessuno non
c'è nessuno perfetto ok c'è qualcuno non
so dove c'è qualcuno non so dove fa
questo quadro serva qualcosa ma questo
caso non serve un cazzo prodi qua c'è
qualcosa di qua c'è qualcosa ha sfondato
il vetro aiuta dove sono
cos'è sta roba cos'è questo bioshock
ragazzo o una tortura di saw l'enigmista
oppure è bioshock cioè non ho capito
bene la neve non importa andiamo avanti
e buio quindi promette bene
raga penso che sia di quella strada
perché dovevo prima ci sono già passato
non è di qua porca [ __ ]
quindi devo capire cosa fare allora di
qua non ci andiamo a perfetto di
conoscere si possa sentirti ce l'ha
scritto puoi sentirmi raga allora si
possa sentirti c'è una plaga dico non
c'era ancora andato c'è qualcosa qui ci
sono i dormitori
non mi piacciono i dormitori non mi
piacciono dimmi qual è il tuo lettuccio
ficcati nelle lenzuola e non rompere il
cazzo
è un three c'è un triciclo qui atomica
raga questo è quello di shining
eh no lo dire di psycho per ragazzi
affetto
[Musica]
la rete
senti e amica tua quella no perché c'è
una che gratta sul muro e non è normale
senti e io ho un amichetto qui è un
amichetto che non lo sa ma quest'anno
dio questo in quella di the walking dead
ma che cazzo ci fa qui se senti un
attimo celio c'è un tuo amico qui
fate conoscenza fate quello che volete
ma io non gratto i muri normalmente
quindi no no stai con lei perché devi
venire con me sì che cazzo cos'è questa
c'è qualcosa c'è un trenino è tuo ma
perché vuoi venire dal cielo a bambina
lì ma che cazzo perché levi non per il
cazzo a me perché porca [ __ ] perché
questo devo fare quixa sono ste stanze
ci sono pezzi di trenino ragazzi sono
prezzi ovunque cosa devo fare qui
senti zia dammi la mano cosa devo fare
qui sono mica tuoi pezzi di trenino 20
un attimo se io ti aiuta ad eva che
cazzo è cosa è successo cosa che cazzo
aiuto sta arrivando
se qualcuno aiuto aiuto aiuto aprile
armadio armadio free qualcosa
raga c'è qualcuno c'è qualcuno che sta
dice il tipo di prima ragazza il tipo di
prima l'ho visto non sono pazzo
la bambina forchetta vieni qui chiuditi
dio mio non ci credo perché deve essere
così visto gioco di merda cos'è star
l'ho visto lo ha visto non mi prendete
per il culo lo avete visto anche voi la
mammina ancora qui
cazzo di dov'è andato era lì c'è viso
era qui vi giuro non mi sono sognato
tutto
vabbè raga io andrei avanti dato che
quella era una delle tante stanze che
ancora dobbiamo vedere raga io stanotte
non dormo
grazie mille per avermi consigliato non
meramente non me lo avete mostrato poi
questo l'ho visto io per una volta va
bene
infatti sono sono un deficiente sono un
pazzo
ecco io mi chiuderei volentieri qui
dentro e non riuscirai più anche se non
so quanto può servire però tu puoi farlo
volendo novero devi non per mica so bene
vabbè comunque orientiamoci un attimo
allora di ricci siamo stati devo andare
di qua di qua ci sarà una porta chiusa
no non c'è una porta chiusa incredibile
non ci
ma quante strade ci sono porca [ __ ]
dove devo andare laga è un'acqua c'è
un'altra stanza aperta poi c'è l'altro
sa da quanti corridoi ci sono cazzo raga
io mi perdo qui cioè non possa andare
avanti a riccò se non ci credo non ci
credo l'ho ritrovata ed è sparito anche
il bambino non mi sta seguendo più
ritrovato la stanza ho vinto
trasferimento in corso
rega sta trasferendo qualcosa raga
probabilmente mi sto sto cambiando zona
non ci posso credere
ho ritrovato la stanza c'è un
caricamento per trasferirsi c'è devo
resistere
datti una cazzo di mossa dati una caz
chiudi la porta
datti una mossa da 60 per cento muovi ti
aiuta però aiuto 70 per cento dio mio fa
che già facciamo fa che ce la facciamo
non c'è ancora nessuno chiuditi aiuto 90
per cento no 95 aiuto chiudi la porta
chiudi la porta cosa uno di 64 ma non ci
voglio credere
ma cos'è ma che cazzo ma [ __ ] c'è
mi avete fatto illudere ce n'era già
dovevo fare 64 caricamenti così c'è
macchietta vabbè raga io direi che però
ci posso concludere qui è traumatizzante
viggiona una cosa assurda
però sono riuscito a finirlo c'è tutto
sommato va bene anche se nel peggiore
dei modi è finito ma vabbè io direi che
per oggi possono chiudere qui selvi dove
è piaciuto come al solito lasciate un
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come in ogni video trovate
nella descrizione se lo siete anche
rischi iscrivetevi noi ci vediamo in un
prossimo video bella ragazzi